foreign
Joe Biden's ongoing Board of Crisis is
hitting New York City very very hard
well the mayor Eric Adams well says this
place is about to be destroyed and
destroyed forever take a look
month after month I stood up and I said
this is going to come to a neighborhood
near you
but we're here
we're here we're getting no support on
this National crisis
and we're receiving no support and let
me tell you something New Yorkers
never in my life have I had a problem
that I did not see in ending to
I don't see an ending to this
this issue
will destroy New York City
destroy New York City
all right in Queens New York well
residents there got a little preview of
The Coming disaster today Local Schools
uh were completely overwhelmed and
inundated by the children of illegal
immigrants uh forcing some students to
move into overflow spaces now apparently
schools were even handing out free
backpacks school supplies paid for
Courtesy of New York taxpayers to
illegal immigrants children and while
the mayor and his Democratic friends
he's out there blaming Texas governor
Greg Abbott for bussing illegals into
the city well even the left-wing New
York Times They were forced to admit
that it was around a little over 13
000 illegal immigrants was sent up from
Texas the rest of them came from Joe
Biden his White House nearly a hundred
thousand anyway joining us now to
discuss this and by the way he may be
holding let's just say what do we want
to call it a bridge blocking soon former
New York City Republican mayoral
candidate is with us
and uh Sean yeah soon could be the next
mayor of the city of New York because
I'm coming after Eric Adam who's
destroyed our city
it's not just New York though it's every
city it's every small town because
they're being sent all around the
country all right so well over a hundred
thousand illegal immigrants he says it's
going to cost your City because I hate
this place not my city I'm getting the
hell out of here as soon as I can all
right your city is billions and billions
of dollars Curtis that's a fortune the
city can't afford that they're not even
housing our homeless vets okay so now
we've got all these children showing up
in schools we're barely 40 percent of
the kids already are proficient Reading
Writing and math okay now what are they
going to do with all these kids most of
which who can't speak English how
they're going to handle that Sean before
you even get to that it's a state law
that says every child I've had three
sons in public school must be vaccinated
from A to Z or you don't step in the
front door now all these illegal alien
kids close to 22 000 no vaccinations no
medical record we don't even know who
they are there's nobody there's no old
paperwork and yet they moved to the Head
of the Class and you say why are we
forcing American children to the back of
the class you wanted them in Joe Biden
the Biden in Brooklyn that was Eric
Adams remember he said I'm the Biden in
Brooklyn Kathy hokel you say you're a
sanctuary state of sanctuary City well
take what you said you were going to do
and do it or stop complaining you don't
need to be a sanctuary City because
there's no laws there's no law that says
that it's not just education it's food
it's housing it's clothing it's it
medical help all of that paid for
Courtesy of the taxpayers New York can't
afford this by the way Wall Street alone
took in the last couple of years a a
billion dollars out of New York City and
that's just part of The Exodus out of
the city there's been a mass Exodus out
of New York and that exists continues
even with a second hurricane in Florida
you would think people would reconsider
High property taxes no flood insurance
no people are still saying we're going
to Florida The Exodus is unbelievable
the buses go down right with New Yorkers
and they come back with illegal aliens
yeah so that's how they nourish the
population how crazy is that you know
one of the greatest statistics I saw
because California has this Mass Exodus
going on as well okay and for the first
time in their history they're losing
population all right everyone go west
young man go to the Golden State go you
know there's your opportunity people are
leaving because of high taxes burdensome
bureaucracy all the reasons that we
talked about a sanctuary State Sanctuary
cities all throughout California and
people are leaving as with it the tax
base is leaving uh now you see what's
happening out there and then you have
people arrested and they're not put in
jail they put you in jail oh absolutely
fingerprint me and photograph me like
they did Trump and Giuliani I'm saying
for what right a desk appearance ticket
an illegal alien when the cops arrest
them they don't know who they are and
immediately they say Asylum Seeker
Asylum you can't touch them they were
Untouchable they can murder rape rob
steal they're Untouchables they were
sworn they took an oath to the
Constitution to protect America and
protect us the American city citizens
they have forsaken us forsaken us for
illegal aliens if you love the illegal
aliens so much go to Venezuela go to
Mexico El Salvador Honduras go out of
this country to the places that you're
inviting people in and imagine if you
happen to be those illegals and you're
looking at this you see I can't believe
that bullets are open I get to stay in a
hotel three squares iPhone smartphone oh
culturally appropriate food Conor Rosa
Beach
or pork chop on top and if I'm not happy
they send GrubHub if you're an illegal
alien you're joining The Invasion and
they are going going to overwhelm us I
will not allow that I am the mayor in
Exile like Napoleon on the island of
Elba I will block the bridges I will
stop the buses we will turn them around
so back to where you came from you don't
belong here you're illegal you have held
a number of demonstrations you are now
threatening to shut down the bridges in
New York City how real is that threat oh
very real you've seen this before and
it's truckers who are the most patriotic
to most American the independent truck
is 18 wheel tractor trailer drivers are
willing to risk their rigs they will
block every entrance and exit they will
take the keys out walk away and say
tough noogies you're not coming in to
our city or state and our country
anymore if the politicians won't do it
the people will do it do you think a
city like New York and by the way you
did well considering you know you're out
registered by democrats nine to one yes
do you think politically it would be
possible for you to pull off a massive
upset because of this issue and run
against Eric Adams and beat him in New
York City are enough New Yorkers fed up
with us John I won't win the election
Eric Adams will lose the election
because he has forsaken the voters
especially African-Americans who thought
that to the Victor go that spoils he
said I was going to take care of my
people the ones who live in the streets
who have drug problems alcohol problems
are in the shelters are emotionally
disturbed the majority are
African-Americans they look at me every
day they say Curtis this guy stabbed
this in the back he's taking care of
people he doesn't even know what their
name is where they're from and we are
told to go to the back of the bus gee
whiz blacks Ford for years to get to the
front of the bus and yo homeboy Eric
Adams has put them in the back of the
bus and pretty soon they'll be wanting
to go to Florida Georgia North Carolina
and South Carolina Virginia Tennessee
Texas and parts are known to get the
hell out of here well I think Curtis
needs to come out of his shell
um
great to see you Curtis
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else